I had my reservations at first because I
thought high-maintenance it's gonna be a
pot show and it's gonna be just a stone
or show and all stoner humor and it's
not yes it's it's very hard to describe
but just a great look at so many
different kinds of lives and also very
funny at the same time yeah yeah that
seems like almost a full complement I
like that
it's the most I can do at this time a
full complement takes it's way too much
work for me no I hear I really do I
really do love the show what I did find
interesting is that your your character
as a pot dealer as a drug dealer you you
wanted to learn more about the character
so you did research of course yeah yeah
well I will say that the summer that the
show was conceived there was there was
plenty of research
yeah it's summer yeah not just with you
you didn't just experiment with
marijuana and types of marijuana don't I
sound old now I sound like an 80 year
old narc
various grains of reefers yes these jazz
cigarettes you smoke but you tried you
tried ayahuasca which is intense stuff
oh yeah well basically it's it's loaded
with this key ingredient DMT which is
actually flowing through all of our
bodies and organically all the time
what yeah did you say endo gently and
organically we meant you're getting the
only stoner that gets smarter than just
means inside
yeah he's he should be doing I know no
no no I don't like puking yeah wasps can
make you throw up it's supposed to I
went into it wanting to write an episode
about it I was basically cheating off
everybody else's like spiritual homework
and I didn't nothing not nothing
happened to me I certainly didn't puke
though but did you have a great high I
mean was it an amazing high I've heard
it's very intense I mean a lot of people
crying and going through their traumas
and me would recommend it that's the
other thing to it I was thinking about
that wait a minute
crying puking wherever there are people
who accidentally relieve themselves yeah
where's the upside where's that what
makes you want to go to an ayahuasca
party the upside is on the other side of
it you feel for about a week afterwards
you feel unconditional love towards
everyone and everything for a little
while and that's like yeah not worth it
also worth it that can also get you in
trouble on the bus
and it has yeah